okay let's get going here so this week
I'll be talking about bacteria and
viruses and these are really significant
topics because I think it's something
that we often don't think about the
magnitude of the problems and how what
kind of crises were approaching with
respect to the therapeutic treatment of
infectious disease so what I want to try
and get home to you this week is the
variety of different microorganisms that
threaten our health and just talk to you
about the sorts of issues that are
really prominent in the news concerning
resistance to therapeutic agents but in
order to do that we've got a meats and
bacteria meet some viruses and
understand that some of their lifestyles
their mechanisms so that we can
understand what kinds of agents are used
and developed to try to mitigate these
diseases because it's only through a
molecular mechanistic understanding of
the life cycles of viruses and bacteria
that we can understand how many of these
therapeutic agents work and what may be
happening in resistance development now
I find this this particular slide a
little sort of daunting but I want to
point out to you that it it concerns the
world's deadliest animals so we worry a
lot about tigers and sharks and things
like that
nasty poisonous snakes bites from dogs
with rabies and so on I'm going to leave
this black bar here sort of unmentioned
I don't know what year this is but talk
about daunting that's pretty serious and
then the the biggest killer on this
screen is the mosquito but it isn't
actually the mosquito it's the protozoa
microorganisms that the mosquito carries
from one person to another that really
makes that such a deadly such a serious
consideration but what's not here are
all the bacteria and viruses that
actually are far more serious and the
numbers on the next stage will show you
just quite how shocking these numbers
are if you're interested
infectious disease as a field because I
think it's really anyone going towards
MD MD ph.d infectious diseases really a
critical area that we have to get to
grips with then not enough vaccines in
the world there is not enough treatment
with a very microbe specific
anti-infective agents so so I encourage
you to look at the CDC there's a few
other places where there's loads of
information collated such as the ni a a
ID which is the NIH Center for
infectious disease and the World Health
Organization so there's lots of places
where you can find stuff out so what
we're gonna be talking about in the next
three classes are our smallest enemies
things like bacteria fungal infections
from things like yeast or Aspergillus
which would cause candida and
aspergillosis protozoal disease we won't
mention but those are the types of
diseases that are carried by things like
ticks mosquitoes tsetse flies a lot of
we think of those as the infectious
agent but it's really what those those
organisms carry and and cause the spread
of disease that's important there and we
won't either talk about prion diseases
which are the diseases that don't
involve an infectious microorganisms but
are believed to be spread from protein
to protein through the nucleation of new
prions from existing prions what we'll
focus on in the first class is on
bacteria and in the other two on viruses
with an eye to looking at antibiotics
and antiviral agents how they work where
they go wrong and this is where the
numbers get fairly shocking so for
example bacterial infections of the
lower respiratory tract so that's deep
in the lungs caused four million deaths
a year think back to the numbers you
just saw on that first slide these are
things like strep pneumonia pneumonia
clips Yellin pneumonia
they're called pneumonias
they're infectious diseases of the lung
but the organisms that cause them are of
the streptomyces in Klebsiella and
Staphylococcus aureus specifically but
there are others that cause lung
infections and lower respiratory disease
these are particularly troublesome in
areas where the atmosphere is bad in big
cities where there's a lot of insult
from emissions and such that make the
lungs weaker then these these sorts of
organisms can really take a hold more
readily so they are more serious there
are many many microorganisms that cause
pneumonia eyes and sometimes it's a real
problem to track down the precise
microorganism which makes the issue of
treatment really difficult really
challenging so I'm going to talk in a
minute about absolute identification of
infectious agents so we can do better
jobs of specifically targeting the
causes of the causative agents diarrheal
disease 2 million deaths these are
organisms like Campylobacter jejuni and
Salmonella enterica we tend to have
these sort of crises because you know
romaine lettuce is God is contaminated
with infection there are very few deaths
in the developed world we get down to
that very quickly say stop eating
romaine lettuce till we figure out
what's going on here very very few but
once again in the developing world these
can run rampant and they could grab
small children and older people who are
already compromised already a little bit
not quite with strong immune systems and
people generally die of dehydration
because these diseases really hit the GI
tract cause leakiness in the GI tract
and really really serious diarrheal
disease so those are the bad boys there
but once again there are many others
tuberculosis is yet another really
serious infectious disease caused by
Mycobacterium tuberculosis
the main one of the the mycobacteria
that is a threat it used to be called
consumption in the old days because
people almost looked consumed by the
disease they would just get thinner and
thinner and literally it was a wasting
disease people would be sent up into the
mountains of Switzerland to try to
recover from consumption to where the
air is clearer and cleaner and maybe
hope that they can recuperate but TB
look at these numbers in 2015 there were
almost 10 million new cases there's
about 1.2 million deaths from TB and the
serious situation with TB is that it's
often found Co infecting with the HIV
virus where you just can't fight the TB
so eventually if you're infected with
the HIV virus it's the TB that gets you
due to the the weakening caused by the
infection with TB so these numbers are
shocking in light of the numbers I
showed you on the previous slide right
look at these numbers you know for if
you go sort of to snakes and things like
that they're meaningless numbers
compared to infectious diseases ok so
there's now and I'm gonna talk to you
about the oranges of the through your
interest the origins of this many many
infectious agents that we thought we had
conquered we thought we could take care
of it you just take this course of
antibiotics and you're off your set but
now because of the rapid mutation rates
in bacteria and viruses certain
pathogens have completely worked out
mechanisms to escape therapeutic agents
but I'm going to talk to you about those
mechanisms towards the end of this class
so basically you can dose a person one
day with a normal dose of an antibiotic
agent and then ten months later that
normal dose or ten times or a hundred
times that dose stops working why is
that is due to resistance acquisition
due to rapid cell division and
mistakes made on repla on replication
and transcription that then may one in a
million times confer an advantage on
microorganism all of a sudden the drugs
don't work anymore and there's a series
the w-h-o and various of the sort of
community and noticeboards call this set
of infectious agents the escaped
pathogens it helps us remember which
ones these are because these are
pathogens that escaped treatment because
they've developed resistance to multiple
drug cocktails so commonly when someone
has a particular disease they don't take
one drug they take two or three to kinda
hit lots of pathways at once in the hope
the resistance won't develop fast but
the escaped pathogens have collectively
acquired resistance to several
antibiotics meaning there's no good
treatment and here so the letters of
escape stand for Enterococcus faecium
staph aureus Klebsiella pneumoniae
Acinetobacter baumannii Pseudomonas
aeruginosa and some of the enterobacter
species some of these infectious agents
are what are called result from I always
get this spelled said wrong nosocomial
infections does anyone know what those
are
these are infections that people get in
hospitals so you go like Tom Brady had a
knee operation he got an infection in
his knee that came from the surgery
right
these are hospital acquired infections
because you know you can't sometimes
clear an area enough and there's
infectious agents around so I seen
Acinetobacter baumannii was dubbed the
Iraqi bug for many many years because
the vets coming back from Iraq were
going to military hospitals and these
were abundant with court cases of
Acinetobacter baumannii so that moved on
to the escaped pathogen list so these
are things to watch out for
it's the reason nosocomial infections
I hope I'm saying it right otherwise
you're gonna go off and google it and
realize I said it wrong it's the reason
why old-school physicians wore bow ties
and not ties
can you understand can you imagine why
so if you're wearing a tie which I
seldom wear to be honest and you're
overworking over a patient the tie can
be the thing that carries the infection
because it gets closer to infected areas
this is old-school stuff and so
originally the physicians were bow ties
in order to distinguish themselves as
the important people but not to wear
ties that might carry infectious agents
and that's sort of a scary thing okay so
with all this said let me just lead you
in to talk about bacteria antibiotics
and resistance development so we often
name bacteria somewhat by their shape so
the long rod shaped ones are cocci sorry
the round ones are cocci the rod ones
whatever they are come on one of you and
then what does the rod shape once
bacilli sorry I had a blank moment so
the rod shape one's a bacilli and then
there's some others that have a
different most morphology like
Campylobacter jejuni that have kind of a
corkscrew shape and that's thought to be
important in their motility digging
through the mucus layers in the
epithelial layers so here I show you
several shapes of bacteria and I'm just
going to once again reinforce which what
diseases some are associated with and
some other diseases that you might be
surprised by so yes we know about
Salmonella and e-coli and food poisoning
but HeLa kaback tapo Laurie which is one
of these flagellated bacteria can infect
the stomach it's often the cause of
ulcers so it's a causative agent of
stomach ulcers but that has in turn led
to a considerable risk factor in stomach
cancer so what we thought was just an
infection has causes a constellation of
other problems in
luding cancers and more and more back to
microbial agents are now associated with
cancers in particular many of the also
the viruses in a Syria these are come
along with the sexually transmitted
diseases such as gonorrhea Nash Syria
Menon Judy DS is the one that causes
meningitis very very often fatal
infections of the maninjau
staph aureus lot of infections around
the body just gruesome things cellulitis
wound infections toxic shock
streptococcal bacteria i've already
mentioned the pneumonias and then
Campylobacter and now another
complicated factor of infections I
talked to you about stomach ulcers and
stomach cancer another thing that seems
to be coming along with infections is
autoimmunity so in the last section of
the class you heard about immunity and
you also heard about tolerance right
that we don't react to things that our
ourselves right otherwise we'd be in
deep trouble autoimmunity can suddenly
pop up from certain bacterial infections
because bacteria tend to cloak
themselves with unusual sugar polymers
and other kinds of structures that the
body doesn't really know what to do with
and in some cases they kind of mimic
things that are in the human body so
they're they're mimic their memetics of
normal structures in the human body and
the body just doesn't notice them at all
and then there are incidences where
certain bacterial infections later on
cause autoimmune disease so a bacteria
may come along it may have something
that looks kind of like something human
but not quite the human body responds
develops antibodies and then they cross
talk back to aspects of our physiology
so Campylobacter jejuni is often a
contaminant in poultry it's a severe GI
infection but later on people get
diseases such as geonbae which is not
neuropathy where the ends of your limbs
become now
and a non-functional so there was a
famous football player the one they
called the refrigerator who had a
serious case of guillain-barre a
resulting from very much an infectious
disease which converted into
autoimmunity all right
so let's now look at antibiotic targets
and to look at antibiotic targets
I think the first clear place to look is
that the bacterial cell wall now when we
first started talking about prokaryotes
things that include bacteria we talked
about the fact that these single-celled
organisms have to have a robust cell
wall to prevent osmotic shock right they
have to have some kind of thing to keep
them from taking up too much water and
basically exploding because of us
osmosis water floods in to balance the
salt concentrations so they have a
complex cell wall which is made of a
macro molecule called kept you know like
an and it's usually one word but I want
to just underline peptidoglycan because
it's a fascinating polymer that's made
out of polypeptides and linear
carbohydrate polymers so if you look at
this typical bacterium this is just a
cartoon of the peptidoglycan so it's a
cross-linked polymer
we're in one direction it has repeating
carbohydrate units I'm not drawing those
complex hexose structures there I'm just
drawing it in cartoon form and those are
carbohydrates known as nag and mam nag
is an asset eel an acetyl glucosamine
it's a hexose sugar nam is an asset
Elmyra minik acid it's another modified
sugar and off of one of those sugars
there's a reactive site that allows you
to basically cross link these polymers
into a meshwork so it's a feat of
engineering to build this amazing
polymer it starts being built on the
inside on the cytoplasm and then the
components get flipped on to the other
side of the cytoplasm of bacteria then
they get polymerized in place to make
this complex mesh work of a polymer that
creates the rigidity of the bacterial
cell wall and it's generically known as
a as a peptidoglycan different bacteria
have different peptidoglycan they're
subtle modifications that might be
specific to particular bacteria of
bacterial sarah but this is the generic
structure where you have a polymer
that's built of sugars you can recognize
the sugar structure they're going in one
direction and a peptide component the
cross links across in order to make this
mesh and bacteria will have different
amounts of this but it'll build up to a
really strong rigid meshwork that's only
a builder things small molecules and
water there's holes and so on but it
creates mechanical rigidity
so that osmotic shock doesn't occur on
the bacteria alright any questions about
that does that make sense so that's in a
sense it's their exoskeleton if you want
to think about it like that
so the properties are rigid without it
the bacteria would suffer osmotic shock
and it's plenty permeable to allow
- milk - nanometer type pause in order
for nutrients and water to go into the
structure people like growing here and
it's living you can see it start to grow
there we go penicillin where you can see
these bacteria it's a bacterial broad
shaking a bacteria there wasn't any
microphone on this pokin holes or cell
wall
boom bacteria is dead look at some of
the bacteria disappearing alright I
guess that's right why okay okay then
we're gonna go back to next slide so
we're gonna leave it let's go back one
okay now what was that okay so I've told
you bacteria would suffer osmotic shock
without peptidoglycan right
those are bacteria that you see popping
as as the person who was talking said
because the peptidoglycan cannot be made
there is an antibiotic that's added it
is penicillin that's added to the
bacteria and it stops as bacteria grow
they have to make a bunch more
peptidoglycan because if you're doubling
you've got to make twice as much pep to
know you've got to double the amounts of
peptidoglycan if you have something that
inhibits the peptidoglycan being made
you have a bathroom that's you know
trying to stretch out what it has it's
not resistant to osmotic shock and what
you saw was the bacteria basically
undergoing cell death the osmotic shock
pretty graphic pretty visual so
penicillin was one of the first
antibiotic that was described for the
treatment of batter of bacterial
infections and we'll go to the timeline
of that in a moment
so when we talk about bacteria the
original definition of bacteria is in
three different subtypes gram-negative
Stram positive and microbacterial this
is actually the first way that people
would take a look at your cell the
bacterial cells and diagnose roughly
what kind of bacteria they were did they
fall which of these broad families did
they fall into because it would help in
defining how you would treat the
infectious disease so I want to show you
the difference between the cell wall of
these various types of bacteria and the
truth is if you have an infectious
disease your your wishes if you had to
pick one of the three that you have a
gram positive disease and I'll explain
why that is in a moment because it's all
to do with how drugs can get into the
bacteria to inhibit vital functions in
order that they die and they don't take
over your system so let's look first at
gram positive bacteria they're shown
here this is a section of a bacterium
gram positive have a single cell wall
and they also have a thick layer of
peptidoglycan so they gain rigidity by
basically having an extracellular thick
layer of peptidoglycan coating them
there's a schematic of it here so here
would be the inner cell wall and here
would be the peptidoglycan shown in
orange and pale buff colored circles so
that would be where they're
peptidoglycan is and then there are some
other glyco conjugates that actually
stick out beyond that but there's only
one cytoplasmic membrane that's the
standard double by layer by layer and
the peptidoglycan is quite thick
relatively 20 to 80 nanometers across so
that's how wide it is and you can if
you've got a if you stained a bacterium
under a microscope you would see that
the thickness of that wall but the
absence of a double wall the
gram-negative bacteria have a double
wall the inner membrane it's pretty
standard
it's just typical phospholipids it looks
like the inner cytoplasmic member
membrane of the gram negative of the
gram positive bacteria and then it has
an outer wall so the inner membrane is
typical and then the outer wall has one
leaflet that looks kind of normal and
then it has a second leaflet that sort
of decorated honestly like a Christmas
tree
there's all kinds of things sticking out
there that interact with hosts that they
infect and so on and the space between
the two walls is called the periplasmic
space
because it's between it's not the
cytoplasm it's what's called under
periplasm now what's interesting about
these the gram-negative bacteria is they
have quite a bit less peptidoglycan only
about seven to eight nanometers so
that's pretty interesting but they sort
of gain robustness from that second wall
structure that's coating on the outside
now their challenge with gram-negative
bacteria
relative to gram positive bacteria is
any drugs you develop have to make a
pretty incredible
targeted at intracellular sites that
have to get through two walls not just
one wall so they are harder to treat and
they also have a lot of characteristics
that make them more prone to resistance
development so I want to point out to
you on this electron micrograph you can
actually see the double wall the dark
band a space and then another dark band
whereas here you see a thin single wall
but you see a lot of junk on the outside
is everyone seeing the differences just
to look at them okay so what's this
grand thing about what does what does
this stand for it simply stands for a
chemical dye that stains capsid oh I
can't and it was invented or discovered
by Professor Graham that was his name so
when someone says you got a grand
positive infection gram-negative
infection it's how those cells look when
they've been treated with this stain
gram positives show up very positive to
the stain because there's
or the peptidoglycan on the outside that
absorbs the dye and shows a strong color
the gram negatives don't show very well
with a gram stain because the
peptidoglycan is tucked in the periplasm
not on the outside of the cell so if
someone does a quick check on a
bacterial streak or an infection that
you have they might treat it with the
Gram stain and say grande positive or
gram-negative just based on that simple
color analysis and so so in one case the
peptidoglycan is abundant and accessible
in the other case it's very very much
thinner and less accessible to the dyes
now this probably looks like stone-age
stuff to you because how much can you
learn by these simple colorimetric
stains we're certainly moving in very
very different directions but let me
just finish off with the third type of
bacteria the micro bacteria which
include Mycobacterium tuberculosis and
they have a different kind of wall again
and they're pretty unusual and they are
really really hard to treat because it's
almost impossible to get therapeutic
agents into micro bacteria I used to
work on a team with Novartis in
Singapore and they said doing anything
with micro bacteria was trying to like
trying to do biochemistry on a wax
candle literally you just can't work
with it because they have a thick
additional wall that's kind of different
again did you have a question so what
they have is a typical cell wall then
some peptidoglycan but then they have
this thick micro bacterial label with a
layer layer which is comprises what are
known as mycolic acids which basically
add this thick layer of greasy
hydrophobic material on the outside of
the back of the micro bacteria that's
pretty impenetrable so that's the the
cell wall is quite different it doesn't
have an outer coat it's like
grande positives in that respect but it
doesn't stain very strongly so it has a
weak what's known as Gram stain so
sometimes if you've got something that
gives a sort of soso response to the
Gram stain you might say oh it looks
like a micro bacterium because of what's
happening now mycobacteria TB is a huge
threat because it needs treatment its
current treatment and it's same
treatment that there's been a rate
that's been around for like thirty years
or something
he's a treatment with four different
antibacterial agents that hit a bunch of
different sites in the lifecycle of the
bacteria it includes these compounds
shown here which are isoniazid
rifampicin ethambutol and pierre-pierre
in Peru as in amide and it's a
six-months treatment with those
medications so handful for different
medications for six months so what they
were realizing in the developing world
is that there was terrible compliance
the drugs are cheap but there was no
compliance people just were not taking
the pills because they're like I'm tired
of taking these pills every day for six
months so what was developed was what's
known as the dots program has anyone
never heard of this is anyone interested
in infectious disease it was a situation
where it was a social system set up in
order to make sure people took these
drugs every day for six months in order
to comply so social workers would go to
the villages in remote areas and watch
people take the medications so it's
directly observed treatment to make sure
they followed through because if they
had regular TB not very resistant TV you
could overcome it provided that you took
these medications but still it's a
hugely debilitating thing to have to
deal with these treatments now there are
two strains of TB one's called MDR
tbh and the other ones called X mdr-tb
you'll occasionally hear of these on TV
Proulx programs
EMDR is resistant to three of the four
medications and XM dr which stands for
extremely multidrug-resistant is
resistant every single one of those
medications new medications different
mechanisms of action are sorely needed
okay all right this is just what things
look like with the gram stain's
so here you see gram positive bacillus
anthracis that's the deep purple rods
you know that's a gram positive because
it's a deep purple stain the other cells
in this picture are white cells so you
can really pick out the gram positive
this is the structure of the chemical
dye that stains peptidoglycan through
absorbing into the peptidoglycan it's a
very sort of physical interaction of the
dye with the polymer and over on this
slide it's a mixture of grand positive
and gram negative and you can pick up
the buzzer the gram positive and
differentiate them from the gram
negative which just stains sort of kind
of weakly pink and then mycobacteria
which a formerly gram positive don't
stain very well because of that thick
mycolic acid hydrophobic wall so what
would you do nowadays
would you pull out a stain and so you
drop it on bacteria and get some vague
response what's open to you now in the
21st century you have a tiny sample of a
bacterium grow it up what would you do
you could tell exactly what it is yeah
you'd PCR up the genomic DNA and then go
match it because the thing that we had
in addition to the human genome there
are thousands of pathogen pathogenic
bacterial sequences that are completely
annotate known the brode has a massive
compilation of these sequences you just
go and you find out what
what the bacterium is based on sequence
so now sequence getting rapid sequencing
efforts maybe they're just you know a
few a number of key places in a genome
that you would go towards and just do a
really fast array and figure out what's
there in within what bacterium it is
which gives you a much better clue as to
how to treat it than the vague ambiguous
stains so even though stains keep going
there's now other ways unfortunately not
everyone has the instrumentation to do
rapid sequencing so nowadays there's a
lot lot of interest in faster dipstick
sorts of tests that can distinguish
between different bacterial strains by
for example interrogating that coat of
glyco conjugates that's on the outside
of the bacterial dipstick paper tests
that can give you an idea of what
organism on what serotypes so you can
move forward and do a much more rational
treatment of those organisms okay yes
all right so where did the antibiotics
first come from any questions so far
okay so where did the first antibiotics
came from from a couple of accidental
discoveries who's heard of the Fleming
the the Fleming experiment who knows
about that discovery of penicillin yeah
so there was an original observation
that predated that which sort of
suggests that Pasteur was a pretty smart
guy because he contributed in a lot of
different areas he discovered that some
bacteria tend to release substances that
kill other bacteria that was in the you
know in the 1870s then later on there
was another sort of thread of antibiotic
agents and it came with the discovery
that weird things like arsenic
derivatives actually showed some some
value in treating the organism that
causes syphilis so talk about the
treatmen being were the cure being worse
than the infection people were being
treated seriously with these arsenic
derivatives in the hope of wiping out
the infectious agent that caused
syphilis but you know sometimes it was a
mixed bag but where things started to
get a little a lot more interesting was
that in 1928 there was this sort of
famous historic story of Fleming
discovering but some bacteria seemed to
be inhibiting inhibited by a particular
particular agent that came from a fungus
and this was the origin of penicillin so
he would have a petri dish where we use
growing bacteria and he noticed that in
some of his samples there was inhibition
of bacterial growth due to an exogenous
agent that it's somehow contaminated the
plates okay so in that story that was
the substance that was named as
penicillin and it in hid the molds from
mold is a fungus actually inhibited the
growth of staphylococcal bacteria and it
was called penicillin and then a lot
more time went by but in the 1940s the
the active ingredient was discovered so
nineteen forties is sort of slap-bang
about I would say in a couple of years
into the Second World War and they were
able to mobilize
the production of this agent towards the
later end of the war people had
penicillin available to them and it's
basically pretty well believed that if
it wasn't for the antibiotic agents that
emerged you know the war ended in 1945
it wasn't for those agents that emerged
though there would have been way way way
more deaths from what it was they were
where they were way too many so
penicillin was the first antibiotic that
was discovered with a discrete mechanism
of action and it was discovered in a
very very important time so that was all
great news penicillin was produced
widely some of you may be allergic to
penicillin
other options nowadays but it's the
cheapest and most viable of the
first-line antibiotics and they will
here we go and this thing this point has
a mind of its own it's sort of changed
his mind but the problem was the
bacterial species started to survive
treatment due to development of
resistance and all of a sudden something
that worked really well wasn't working
anymore so let's try and think about
peptidoglycan what penicillin looks like
and what it does and how penicillin
resistance emerges okay those are the
three things I'm gonna cover here okay
so what does penicillin do penicillin
stops the formation of this big
macromolecular peptidoglycan polymer by
stopping the last cross-linked stopping
the chemistry that happens to join the
peptide chains to make a cross-linked
polymer and anyone who's in a mechanical
engineering area will know that polymers
that are just strands are much weaker
than polymers that are cross-linked
structures which have tensile strength
in both directions so the uncross linked
peptidoglycan was weak and what
penicillin specifically did was inhibit
forming that cross-linked
what does penicillin look like here it
is it's a cool structure omits and not
what's known as a natural product fiber
ring foreing an interesting structure
and what it would do is it would
interact with the enzyme that
cross-linked the peptidoglycan and
basically stop it dead in its tracks
what did the bacteria do the key part of
this structure is this four membered
ring with an amide bond in it the
bacteria evolved an enzyme to chop it
open basically making it completely
inactive so beta-lactamase was evolved
in the bacterial populations it was
probably derived from some other enzyme
that did you know some useful function
but not targeted to the pen
sillens but the bacteria started to
survive because they made a ton of an
enzyme called beta lactamase and then it
completely stopped working so the
chemists came up with other options
because they said well you know if we if
that doesn't work we've got other
antibiotics in our arsenal and there was
there's a compound that was used for
years as a last line of resorts
antibiotic known as vancomycin it was
very very important some very serious
infections and really preserved for that
use and they thought vancomycin might be
a comic might be a drug that just
couldn't be defeated this big molecule
here is vancomycin this little piece of
peptide is actually the peptide that's
in that cross-linked and back to not
vancomycin basically like the gloves sat
on that piece of peptide and stopped it
being cross-linked and what did the
bacteria do they evolved a set of
enzymes to completely change that little
piece of peptide into something the
bound more poorly giving you resistance
to vancomycin as well
so when there's one drug involved it's
pretty easy to get resistance quite
quickly you just mutate one enzyme and
you you get a resistance strain and the
enzyme that can beat the antibiotic will
win okay if you've got a drug that if
you've got a compound that takes five
different enzymes or an antibiotic that
has a very complex mechanism of action
you might say well I will this is never
going to be defeated it took five
additional enzymes to evolve to make the
peptidoglycan a different structure and
it's not that within every bacterium you
mutate five different enzymes and get
them all working as a team what was
happening in these hospitals infections
is that a plasmid with the set of
enzymes was being passed around amongst
bacteria so a new bacterium could
acquire resistance to this compound
without
evolving a whole bunch of new enzymes
but rather bilateral transfer of
plasmids encoding the genes that it took
to make the vancomycin inactive okay all
right
so let me just tell you a few of the
targets and then there's one movie I
want to show you that's kind of cool so
currently when we inhibit bacteria with
antibiotics there are a number of
essential processes that are targeted
with common antibiotics so this would be
a typical bacterium one target of action
is DNA synthesis and in DNA polymer
polymerase and the enzyme that is
targeted is one we've talked about
topoisomerase and that is inhibited by
the fluoroquinolone x' such as
ciprofloxacin that actually targets
specifically the bacterial polymerase so
that's one way inhibit DNA replication
bacteria can't divide another set of in
antibiotics are those that inhibits
protein synthesis so in particular you
know that tunnel that comes out of the
ribosome where the growing polypeptide
chain emerges after reading the
messenger RNA and translating the
messenger into protein there antibiotics
are basically stick in that tunnel and
stop protein synthesis and those are
things like the amino glycosides and
they block exit from the ribosome but
you could imagine that mutating there
are the ones that inhibit cell wall
biosynthesis that I've already talked to
you about the penicillins the vancomycin
and then there are others that inhibit
folate synthesis and then there's a lot
of synthetic drugs but also a lot of
natural product drugs so both nature and
chemistry have teamed up to inhibit all
of these essential steps okay so how do
you test for antibiotic resistance you
use plates where you're growing
particular strains of bacteria on a
plate this would be a colony
it's growing outwards where there's a
colony but there's no growth around it
it means there's something in that plate
that is inhibiting bacterial growth so
these are very clear types of ways that
people check to see if bacteria have
become resistant to drugs you would look
for that zone of inhibition does it
disappear with some of the resistant
strains for example and these get pretty
sophisticated now where you can test a
bunch of antibiotics in one go where
each of these colored dots represents an
area where there's treatment with one
antibiotic or another so what's the
problem the problem is this graph that
as soon as an antibiotic is introduced
just a few years go by and there's
resistance to that antibiotic so
resistance basically is the gradual
acquisition of machinery to somehow
inactivate the antibiotic treatment so
if you take a look here on the top is
when a drug is introduced and on the
bottom is when resistance was developed
so let's go to something we're familiar
his penicillin people introduced about
1940 to the general population by about
47 there was resistant to penicillin and
you can see this is really just a really
serious sort of series of events so what
I want to show you was resistance in
action that'll be the last thing I talk
about today because I just want to give
you a feel for what what does resistance
look like so this was an experiment that
was done at Harvard on just a
visualization of resistance development
I think what's so fascinating is you
could then go back to the plate right
and pluck the first pioneers who cross
that line and find out what that was
what was that mutation that let the
population expand and so on so you could
really map out the entire evolution of
very very strong resistance
so in the next class I'll talk to you
about resistance mechanisms and then
we'll talk about viruses and resistance
to antivirals
you